raiders receiver henry rugs the third
12th overall pick in the draft first
receiver taken a little bit of a scare
recently as he was moving things his
father confirmed that that the injury
happened it was an injury to the thigh
henry ruggs the third is on crutches but
he feels okay he was trying to move a
trailer or something his father said
move furniture or something the trailer
just kind of pinned him against the car
or a wall or something he's pretty much
okay i'm about to go out there and see
him a little bit uh it's like a little
open wound on his leg a little incision
something had stuck him right there on
his thigh there was one report that it
was dangerously close to his femoral
artery which uh i'm no doctor but you do
not want the femoral artery to be nicked
or otherwise punctured uh and uh it's
good that he's okay but look um henry
let me just say this i know you haven't
signed your contract yet but you have
money now you you you need that you need
to you need to pay someone to do these
things and protect the money maker chris
well that that's like first off i mean
john gruden must be like what the heck
can i get one of my good receivers to
stay healthy or what the hell is going
on with me but uh that's the point mike
you're right you know we hear players
talk about so much you know my body is
my temple my body is a business well
this goes into this conversation henry
ruggs you know tell your agent or
whoever i know you haven't signed your
contract like mike said but these days
are over you can't be like pulling a
hamstring or a quad muscle or doing
anything else moving heavy stuff anymore
you got cash in your pocket make people
do it it's it's like a real thing you
know i know my wife used to have to tell
me because we moved a lot of course in
my life you're like like no i paid these
guys a lot of money i don't need you
over here and i wasn't the help anyways
but you know again yeah it's you got to
be a professional now don't worry about
moving things around pay people to do it
it's great excuse to be lazy
protect myself i can't do this i can't
puncture my thigh right i mean what's
the worst get happen well you could
puncture your thigh i mean so uh uh come
on come on henry and yeah john good
what's worse frozen feet or a punctured
thigh
no no way
there's a snake bit at the receiver
position
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports